the suicide squad is an awesome scary
hilarious badass and ultimately
heartwarming movie
it's also a pretty straightforward story
one whose loose ends get wrapped up
pretty thoroughly
well most of the loose ends here are
some of the biggest unanswered questions
in the suicide squad
the first action scene of the movie sees
parts of task force x land in the water
and sets up for a beach assault
blackguard walks out first and reveals
that he sold everyone out to the hostels
completely blowing everyone's cover and
plan he then promptly gets his face
blown off for his troubles and kicks off
a firefight that kills almost everyone
on the beach
this raises the first unanswered
question of the movie how could he have
possibly reached them while locked up
he's in a heavy security prison likely
being monitored for much of the day
how did he find his way around this
especially in the short amount of time
between getting his assignments and
deployment
and contacting the soldiers in corto
maltese seeing as he's the first death
of the movie it's unlikely we'll ever
get the true story
this goes hand in hand with the question
of how black guard betrayed everyone
though she's an expert at appearances
amanda waller doesn't know everything
about everybody
she was after all completely blindsided
by bloodsport's fear of rats
i'm not shaking the rat's hand
and seemingly didn't know that
blackguard was going to blow everyone's
cover immediately
but it's hard not to wonder if she saw
this group which he noted was a
diversion that's even more disposable
than the average task force x operation
this is a pretty pathetic group of
heroes weasel drowns almost immediately
but it's hard to say what weasel could
have contributed under the best of
circumstances
harley is a fan favorite but audience
popularity doesn't make up for the fact
that she doesn't have many skills that
would help in a firefight
and she survived largely by dumb luck
tdk is particularly pathetic
only using his detachable arms to
lightly slap his opponents
characters occasionally remarked that
they didn't pick the team which is true
waller did and she's willing to
sacrifice anything and anyone to get
what she wants
did this group just have bad luck or
were they always cannon fodder
this is one question we know is going to
get some kind of an answer and we've
known for some time
bloodsport shot peacemaker in the neck
and left him to bleed out on the rubble
that's about as certain a kill shot as
one can get like a bloodbath to start
the day
yes the post-credits scene shows
peacemaker in a hospital
and wallace underlings saying that he'll
help save the world this is all setting
up for the hbo max peacemaker series
so there's a near 100 chance that we'll
either see or hear about his rescue and
survival
even so a shot to the neck is a shot to
the neck he may be a fighter but that's
a hard thing to overcome
especially from one of bloodsport's
proprietary bullets we'll just have to
wait and see on this one
either way it just shows what wrestling
fans have known for years john cena
never gives up and recovers from injury
at miraculous speed
let's see if peacemaker can win the
royal rumble
is this thing a dark weasel is the
definition of a throwaway character
in fact we saw the several different
kinds of throwaway he drowns pretty much
right away
with his meaningless death helping set
the movie's comic and violent
sensibilities
but he's also a literal throwaway
character as in he was thrown away out
of a helicopter
but waits a post-credit scene reveals
that weasel survived
he coughs up some water and wonders into
the woods seemingly oblivious to
everything that transpired
now what seriously though what happens
now will we ever see weasel again
did weasel get immunity due to
bloodsport's deal with waller or was he
exempt since he knows nothing of the
hard drive
will weasel become the bigfoot of
courtois maltese there's so many
unanswered questions here
certainly enough to justify a short on
hbo max or at least some bonkers fanfic
the possibilities for more weasel are
endless
amanda waller is a dangerous person to
be associated with under any
circumstances
if you're her enemy you're probably
going to die if you're her ally she
could turn on you the moment you're no
longer useful at which point she doesn't
care if you live or die
even if you're a loyal employee you
might end up in the wrong place at the
wrong time and as a team in the first
suicide squad movie learned she'll
probably kill you herself
given that she once executed her own
team entirely because they accidentally
ended up in a mission they weren't
cleared for it's easy to see why people
fear her
as such she took an incomprehensible
amount of courage for her team to
literally knock her out
and let task force x save the day here
the question is will she let that
violent insubordination stand
the movie ends after staro is defeated
and bloodsport makes his deal with walla
what her team knows of the deal is
uncertain what does matter is that they
struck one of the most dangerous and
vindictive people on earth in the head
and it's hard to see them getting away
with that even if she's not going to
kill them she certainly has other ways
of making their lives hell
and it's unlikely they'll get off
scot-free check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite summer
blockbusters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one